hi guys dr. Berg here in this video I
want to talk about this very interesting
thing called dopamine dopamine is a
neurotransmitter which is a hormone like
communication or message that travels
through the nervous system versus
hormones are communications that travel
through the blood and this
neurotransmitter has the effect of
giving you pleasure ok so it's a
pleasure neurotransmitter does other
things that are involved with reward and
even motion so if you have a problem
with dopamine deficiencies you might
have resting tremors in Parkinson's
which is a different thing but mainly
pleasure it's a feel-good hormone it
also gives you that vitality so if you
could imagine not that you ever took
cocaine but the sensation of taking
cocaine what you would feel like this
heightened pleasure you know ability of
the conquer everything it's only because
cocaine and other drugs stimulate
dopamine so the actual physical feeling
that you have is coming from dopamine
not really the drug the drug is only the
trigger that creates more dopamine in
the body so my thought is why can't we
just increase make sure this is high
naturally right so if you're deficient
in dopamine you lack motivation you lack
that drive you become fatigued you kind
of lose your goals addictions very
addictive personality mood issues
anxiety depression resting tremor things
like that so you can see that this is a
very popular neurotransmitter that
people are trying to increase by doing a
lot of things especially you know drugs
the causes of a dopamine deficiency
would be excessive caffeine can deplete
it but if you it's interesting because
caffeine will initially make you feel
good but if you take too much over time
it kind of decreases the dopamine effect
alcohol will decrease dopamine certain
drugs cocaine all those type of drugs
and even all how the psyche drugs Prozac
Paxil
wellbutrin all of those do increase
Dilton a
so over time it depletes dopamine so
it's a trick because it's you bring it
up and Springs down same thing with like
drugs if you're addicted to drugs you're
going to deplete your dopamine reserves
and it we're caused a necessity to take
more and more more drug over time
insulin sugar will deplete dopamine
stress will deplete dopamine cortisol
from the adrenal will deplete dopamine
low stomach acids if you don't have
enough stomach acid you can't digest
protein in general so you start
developing a problem with making
neurotransmitters in general so you'll
be deficient in a lot of different
transmitters you know transmitters so
the point is how do you know if you're
deficient in semuc acids well number one
do you have heartburn do you have acid
reflux do you get indigestion that would
mean that you're probably deficient in
stomach acids as you age you need more
stomach acid so just by adding website
of vinegar or betaine how to chloride
you can increase your neurotransmitter
reserve okay then we have adrenal stress
the adrenal gland the inside of the
adrenal gland makes dopamine so if your
drina's are burnt out or exhausted
you're not going to make the level of
doping so chronic stress you know all
these things deplete your
neurotransmitters not just dopamine
deficiencies but all the
neurotransmitter deficiencies so here's
some things that you can do of course
don't consume as much caffeine or
alcohol get off the drugs get off the
sugar cut the stress down increase the
acid improve the adrenal but also here's
nutrient Lives you can take tyrosine
that's a natural amino acid that as a
precursor to dopamine you can take elfia
9 which is a precursor to dopamine it
can help build it up it's a natural
amino acid vitamin D getting a lot of
Sun will help recharge and build up
dopamine reserves vitamin b6 + b5 are
two other additional B vitamins that are
necessary in making this
neurotransmitter of course and a lot of
the other videos I talked about you know
all these things will deplete these
vitamins too so
so you may not need these if you stop
taking these right here okay exercise
will also increase dopamine so as you
can see there are things that you can do
about this so I just want to bring your
awareness up that there is a hormone
behind this and if you have any of these
symptoms you might want to do some of
these actions okay thanks for watching
take five do it and where am I going
with this press the subscribe button
forgot the last part and I'm going to
see you next time am I going to I will
press up please and yeah you'll get
future updates that's right updates I
knew there was a word press the
subscribe button and I will keep you
updated on the future events